creo este que ha cumplido las
expectativas de lo que se esperaba de
las primeras palabras de carlos tercero
como nuevo jefe de la corona británica
por supuesto ha habido muy pocas
sorpresas era un discurso muy
institucional muy emotivo un discurso
que desde luego está llamado a pasar a
la historia como el primer discurso del
nuevo rey como la primera vez el nuevo
rey carlos tercero se dirige a sus
súbditos y a la opinión internacional
tenía que mencionar la figura de su
madre de la anterior jefa del estado de
la reina isabel por supuesto era
esperado que mencionara a su esposa
camila a la ya reina consorte me ha
gustado mucho como ha comentado que su
vida va a cambiar y ha hecho referencia
a esas organizaciones de caridad a esas
fundaciones a esas ong con las que
colabora da a las que representa da y da
más visibilidad
porque posiblemente muchas de las
personas que se ven beneficiadas
a través de esas fundaciones y
organizaciones estarían pensando todas
era hora de nosotros porque carlos pasa
a ser rey y no va a tener tiempo para
nosotros entonces uno de los mensajes
principales y más simbólicos de ese
discurso ha sido para ellos decir les ha
dicho
tranquilos que yo ahora voy a tener que
dedicarme a otras cosas pero no por eso
vosotros vais a quedar desatendidos me
ha parecido
importantísimo y muy muy acertado quizá
la única amics no sorpresa pero quizá
una cosa que estábamos en duda así lo
iba a anunciar hoy o no lo iba a
anunciar hoy está esa decisión de
investir a su hijo guillermo como
príncipe de gales porque no es un título
que pasa directamente al heredero a la
corona es decisión del monarca decir si
se lo otorga no o no y en este caso
carlos nos acaba de contar claramente
del futuro de su hijo de yerma es
de perales